bonjour bonjour à tous il est 13h passé
de presque 5 minutes et nous sommes en
direct sur Le Figaro.fr et sur la page
Youtube du Figaro pour parler entre
autres du Pass sanitaire et oui car
c'est aujourd'hui mercredi 9 juin 2021
que ce fameux pas sanitaire entre en
vigueur il sera notamment demandé pour
accéder aux événements regroupant plus
de 1000 personnes et pour répondre à
toutes vos questions sur ce fameux pass
je suis avec Chloé Wattier bonjour
bonjour Bruno Chloé donc qui est
journaliste au Figaro économique au
Figaro économie spécialiste des
questions tech les nouvelles
technologies et je suis également en
liaison Skype avec Vincent Bordenave
est-ce que vous m'entendez Vincent oui
très bien super bonjour Vincent donc
Vincent et journaliste au service
sciences du Figaro il pourra répondre à
toutes vos questions sur l'épidémie de
covid-19 en général sur les vaccins et
sur les nouveaux variants alors
n'hésitez pas à poser toutes vos
questions je vous lis sur le chat donc
du de la page Youtube Le Figaro et sur
le Figaro.fr je vais vous saluer alors
je salue d'ailleurs
songs for pardon song for night qui nous
demandait à quelle heure commence le
live vient de commencer donc si vous
avez des questions sur le Pass sanitaire
sur l'épidémie de covid 19 en général
n'hésitez pas je suis là pour les
relayer alors on va commencer
directement avec ce pas sanitaire Chloé
première question qu'est-ce que se passe
sanitaire et à quoi il va ressembler
alors question simple réponse un petit
peu longue donc je vais essayer de faire
ça de manière plutôt simple pas
sanitaire à quoi il sert l'idée c'est de
permettre de réouvrir des lieux qui
jusqu'à présent était fermé parce que
ils allaient concentrer trop de
personnes au même endroit donc le Pass
sanitaire ça concerne les événements qui
vont regrouper plus de 1000 personnes et
on va monter jusqu'à 5000 personnes ils
pourront pas accueillir plus de 5000
personnes jusqu'au 30 juin donc
concrètement qu'est-ce que c'est ça va
être les festivals par exemple Festival
de Cannes festival de
dans les Eurockéennes les francophones
enfin voilà les festivals de musique ça
va être ça ça va être également les
salons professionnels ça va être les
parcs d'attractions ça va être
tout ce qui est match de foot match de
foot également tout ce qui est tout ce
qui a lieu à trait au sport enfin bref
tous les endroits où on va regrouper
beaucoup de monde et que jusqu'à présent
ben voilà on pouvait pas rouvrir parce
que c'était un peu trop compliqué un peu
trop dangereux au niveau sanitaire et
donc se passe qu'est-ce qui va prouver
se passe il va prouver non pas que vous
êtes vacciné en fait ça c'est une des
options possibles en fait il va prouver
que vous n'avez pas le covid donc c'est
soit parce que vous avez terminé tout
votre cycle de vaccination donc ça je
pense qu'on pourrait revenir après sur
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire concrètement
soit vous avez un test PCR ou
antigénique négatif
donc ça c'est les deux grosses deux
grandes catégories et ensuite quelle
forme il va prendre là aussi je vais
rester très très simple très schématique
il y a deux formes principales c'est
soit format papier donc quand vous
passez un test covid ou quand vous avez
une vaccination on va vous remettre un
certificat donc ce certificat vous
pouvez l'avoir au format papier donc
soit vous le remet directement en papier
soit vous allez l'imprimer de votre côté
donc ça vous pouvez toujours présenter
du papier c'est pas il y a pas de
problème l'autre format c'est le format
numérique et dans ce cas là il va
falloir utiliser l'application tous
antico vide
donc on n'est pas obligé de télécharger
cette application c'est une question qui
revient assez fréquemment on peut
toujours se déplacer avec son
attestation papier comme l'attestation
déplacement dérogatoire à l'époque
tout de suite me vient en tête une autre
question comment l'État ou les
organisateurs de festival plutôt vont
pouvoir vérifier que les papiers fournis
sont sont vraies alors ça aussi ça a été
une très très grosse question donc là
c'est bon tout est en oeuvre tout est
prêt ça fait depuis environ deux mois à
peu près que quand vous passez un test
antigénique ou PCR quand vous si vous
avez la curiosité de regarder le papier
qu'on vous remet à la fin vous verrez de
ce qu'il y a un
QR code et en fait ce QR code or très
exactement c'est un Datamatrix si on est
très technique c'est une preuve
certifiée comme quoi le papier est vrai
que le document est certifié il est
véritable que ce n'est pas un test que
vous avez voilà un résultat de test que
vous avez fait vous-même que vous avez
acheté sur internet que c'est pas une
contrefaçon donc ce date à Matrix en
fait il va être scanné et il remonte
pour faire de manière très schématique
ça va être scanner ça va remonter dans
les serveurs de l'État dans les serveurs
de ministère de la Santé pour dire oui
cette signature on va dire une sorte de
signature électronique cette signature
est véritable ce document est officiel
ce n'est pas une contrefaçon donc le
résultat qui est indiqué dessus est vrai
alors j'ai une question de yasuline dans
le chat du figaro.fr bonjour yasuline
Merci de Yves à souligne pardon merci de
nous suivre en direct une question
comment les touristes étrangers pourront
faire valoir leur vaccination réaliser
en dehors de la France moyennant carte
et QR code alors ça ça va être aussi une
grosse question pour le moment c'est
résolu pour les touristes européens donc
à partir de la début juillet de début
juillet tous les tests certificat de
vaccination etc qui proviennent de
l'Europe seront reconnus en France il y
aura en fait dans tous les pays
européens il ira le même système qui
sera mis en place avec ses certificats
avec des QR codes et qui sont certifiés
authentifiés on sait que ce sont des
certificats véritables en fait c'est ce
qu'on appelle alors c'est le fameux
passeport sanitaire européen dont on
parle beaucoup c'est ça le principe
c'est que chaque pays européen donc les
27 pays européens mettent en place leur
système national
et ensuite on fait en sorte que ces
systèmes nationaux communiquent entre
eux donc par exemple vous êtes un
touriste grec ou lituanien vous venez en
vacances à Paris votre vos certificats
seront écrits dans la langue de votre
pays donc peut-être que la personne en
face qui va devoir regarder voir cette
votre certificat va dire ouh là en fait
je comprends rien et ben là on se canant
il sera tout de suite si oui non vous
pouvez rentrer parce que il y a ce
système sécurisé qui s'est mis en place
pour dire oui ce certificat est
authentique et même si je ne comprends
pas ce qui a marqué sur le papier parce
que c'est pas dans ma langue natale et
ben je sais voilà il y a une couleur
verte qui s'affiche sur mon écran de
contrôle la personne peut rentrer
song for night donc vous nous avez
rejoint encore sur le chat de la page
Youtube du Figaro qui nous demande
bonjour allez vous répondre à toutes les
questions des internautes et bien oui
son sport night posé donc votre question
on va essayer d'y répondre dans la
mesure du possible si Vincent oucloé
n'ont pas la réponse nous essayons de
vous renvoyer peut-être vers un site qui
pourra vous apporter une réponse donc
n'hésitez pas à poser votre question
Vincent je vais m'adresser à vous Chloé
a abordé tout à l'heure un chapitre qui
est plutôt pertinent pour le concernant
le Pass sanitaire c'est le circuit de
vaccination donc quand est-ce qu'on est
à jour dans son pass sanitaire
concernant les différents types de
vaccins contre le covid qui existe
alors ce qui a été venu dans le cadre du
Pass sanitaire c'est une vaccination
complète plus ce 14 jours
la vaccination complète c'est deux doses
de vaccin pour les vaccins moderna
Pfizer ou AstraZeneca ou une seule dose
de vaccin pour les vaccins j'enseigne
Johnson et Johnson mais ça peut être
aussi une seule dose de vaccin pour
toutes les personnes qui sont en
capacité présenter une preuve de
une preuve de sérologie positive c'est à
dire qu'ils ont été malades du covid et
qu'ils ont sont guéris ils ont des
anticorps dans dans le sang qui qui sont
toujours présents et à partir du moment
présent de cette preuve au moment où on
doit se faire vacciner on n'a pas besoin
de deuxième dose la première dose permet
de boucler le schéma vaccinal il faut
attendre 14 jours aussi pour pour le
Passat
pourquoi ce délai de 14 jours ça a été
expliqué
scientifiquement il y a pas d'éléments
vraiment tangibles qui font qu'on va
plus vers 10 jours plus qu'un jour plus
deux semaines ce que montre les données
les retours des pays où la vaccination a
démarré un peu en avance par rapport à
la France donc c'est que ce soit Israël
ou le Royaume-Uni c'est que les vaccins
sont très efficaces trois semaines après
la première injection et que la deuxième
injection permet de maintenir sur un
temps sur un temps long cette efficacité
mais cette efficacité est variable d'un
vaccin à un autre et variable d'un
individu à un autre donc prendre 14
jours c'est faire un choix de la
sécurité et de s'assurer une efficacité
maximale autour de 90% 85 90% pour pour
tous les vaccins
alors que répondre Chloé ou Vincent que
répondre à ceux qui disent que on peut
toujours attraper le covid en étant
vacciné
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à ça
on peut toujours attraper le colis dans
les temps vaccinés les vaccins ce que je
disais ils sont efficaces à plus de 90 %
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a quand même
une personne sur 10 qui vacciner peut
plus attraper le covid mais attraper
covid ça peut vouloir tout et rien dire
c'est à dire que si attraper covid c'est
avoir le nez qui coule la gorge la gorge
qui gratte et un peu de fièvre c'est pas
très grave si attraper le covid c'est de
voir subir une hospitalisation des soins
intensifs là ça devient plus inquiétant
et ce qu'on commence à avoir avec les
vaccins c'est que les personnes qui sont
contaminées après avoir été vaccinés
sont extrêmement rares à aller à
l'hôpital la nécessité des soins
supplémentaires à faire même des formes
des formes symptomatiques
au-delà pas forcément grave mais fort
c'est-à-dire de la fièvre des fortes
toux etc
on marque on remarque une efficacité qui
est même proche qui est même proche des
100% ce qu'il s'agit de de la
réanimation donc on peut rattraper covid
on peut tomber malade avoir le nez qui
coule etc mais les formes graves les
hospitalisations sont quand même sont
quand même sont quand même très très
rares et c'est ça le but des vaccins
alors sans que fortnite dans le chat de
la page Youtube du Figaro nous pose du
coup une question peut-être pour pour
vous Chloé ne pensez-vous pas que le
Pass sanitaire soit une atteinte grave à
la liberté individuelle de nos citoyens
qu'est-ce que la cnilandit par exemple
alors la CNIL a validé le principe du
Pass sanitaire en apportant pas mal de
bémol en fait justement pour préserver
les libertés surtout faire en sorte que
les données de santé des Français ne
soient pas mal utilisé en tout cas ça ne
se retrouve pas dans la nature donc
l'acné l'a apporté quelques garde-fous
par exemple elle a demandé au
gouvernement de préciser précisément
quels sont les lieux dans lequel le Pass
sanitaire va devoir être exigé parce que
c'était un petit peu flou sur la
première version du texte du
Gouvernement donc là maintenant on a une
liste précise l'acné là également
demandé à ce qu'il soit marqué
clairement dans la loi que les lieux qui
ne sont pas concernés par le Pass
sanitaire ne puisse pas exiger la
présentation n'a pas sanitaire donc je
prends un exemple vous êtes un
organisateur de mariage vous avez une
salle voilà qui à faire des mariages
vous pouvez pas dire pour rassurer vos
clients oui je vais exiger que vos
invités présentent à pas sanitaire comme
ça vous pourrez faire la fête de manière
un peu plus avec l'esprit un peu plus
léger ils n'ont pas le droit de faire ça
et s'ils le font il s'exposent à un an
d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros d'amende
[Musique]
alors si vous nous rejoignez n'hésitez
pas à poser toutes vos questions à Chloé
Voitier journaliste tech au Figaro
économie et Vincent Bordenave qui est en
Skype avec nous depuis le deuxième étage
du Figaro depuis la rédaction il est
journaliste au service science on répond
à toutes vos questions sur le Pass
sanitaire mais aussi sur l'épidémie de
covid-19 en général d'ailleurs juste
derrière moi Vincent une question pour
vous on voit derrière moi donc sur ce
graphique dans la source et covid
tracker le nombre de cas quotidiens
positifs du covid on voit qu'il y a une
très forte dégrade dégringolade est-ce
que vous pouvez commenter ces chiffres
quelle est la situation sanitaire du
pays à l'instant T
oui bien sûr je peux commencer ces
chiffres la situation est à
l'amélioration et la nette amélioration
depuis
bientôt deux mois maintenant donc on a
donc c'est on devine sur le sur le
tableau à peu près 6000 nouvelles
tests nouveau test positif par jour ce
qui fait que le nom de ma réflexion est
sans doute un peu plus élevé mais en
détecte peu près 6000 cas il y a à peine
une dizaine de jours on était à plus de
10000 cas donc on voit que la tendance
est à la baisse et ce qui est très
important c'est qu'elle est non
seulement à la baisse au nombre de cas
mais à la fois sur les hospitalisations
à la fois sur les admissions réanimation
et aussi sur la mortalité donc tous les
indicateurs sont au vert et il est même
assez probable et même
que l'on arrive au fameux 5000k qui
était le seuil brandi par le Président
de la République en novembre dernier
pour envisager un déconfinement même
s'il a jamais été atteint à ce moment-là
mais il est très possible que dans les
un jour même d'ici la fin de la semaine
on atteint ces 5000 cas par jour ce qui
est très important parce que 5000k c'est
la limite pour pouvoir surveiller chaque
chaque nouveau cas c'est à dire
comprendre d'où vient la contamination
faire en sorte à ce qu'il y ait pas de
contamination à partir de d'un test
positif et on estime qu'entre aux
alentours de 5000 cas on peut avoir une
très très bonne gestion d'épidémie et
empêcher un rebond empêcher les un
regain épidémique malgré des clusters
etc
est-ce qu'on a des explications à cette
amélioration de tous les indicateurs
est-ce que c'est la couverture vaccinale
qui a démarré chose qui joue il y a eu
quand même un
pseudo-confinement il y a il y a deux
trois mois avec les écoles fermées
pendant trois semaines qui ont permis de
lancer une dynamique une dynamique
importante
le covid c'est une épidémie qui a
beaucoup de force d'inertie donc à
partir du moment où la dynamique est
lancée elle se prolonge et ensuite on a
bénéficié aussi d'une couverture
vaccinale beaucoup plus forte qui
continue progresser et qui fait que le
nombre de personnes
susceptibles d'être contaminé et chaque
jour un peu un peu moins élevé donc
c'est cet aimant là qui joue et enfin il
y a aussi la question climatique alors
ça ça reste assez mystérieux et les
scientifiques continuent de discuter
d'essayer de comprendre quel impact avec
l'humain mais on sait qu'en fonction
d'une certaine d'un certain taux
d'humidité il y a une certaine
température le le virus est moins
contagieux là on arrive dans la période
la plus positive pour nous on l'avait vu
l'été dernier
pendant des périodes aussi sèches que le
mois de juin juillet et août le virus
est un peu moins contagieux qu'il n'est
en novembre décembre janvier mars et
donc c'est cette combinaison de facteurs
qui explique ça il faut pas oublier
quand même ce petit confinement qui a
qui a permis d'enfléchir la courbe et
après la dynamique des lancers à la fois
par la vaccination à la fois par par la
météo et aussi par les gestes barrières
que la plupart d'entre nous ont
systématisé on a apprivoisé
alors song for night vous remercie Chloé
pour pour votre précision et votre
réponse et rebondit sur une autre
question elle vous demande si cette
première version du Pass sanitaire et
peut-être une porte qui s'ouvre une
future génération généralisation du Pass
à des domaines plus quotidiens comme
pour un mariage etc est-ce qu'il est
possible que se passe soit étendu donc à
d'autres applications que celles pour
lequel il est présenté aujourd'hui alors
ça aussi ça a été une des demandes de la
CNIL donc le Pass sanitaire ne durera
que le temps que jusqu'au 30 septembre
en fait c'est la fin de la je vais le
terme exact un peu le régime des
sections d'exceptions dans lequel on est
à cause de la crise sanitaire donc 30
septembre passe sanitaire disparaît donc
il faudra repasser par tout un si jamais
on souhaite le réactiver il va falloir
repasser par tout le processus pardon
législatif qu'on a vu ces derniers ces
dernières semaines pour pouvoir remettre
en place un pass sanitaire donc ce sera
quand même assez compliqué ensuite voilà
sur la question des restaurants
cinéma etc donc on le rappelle le Pass
sanitaire ne sert pas à aller au
restaurant ne sert pas à aller dans les
barres de sert pas aller au cinéma ce
n'est pas du tout son but ça c'est autre
chose qui est le carnet de rappel qui
est souvenez-vous l'année dernière il
fallait quand on allait au restaurant
remplir un petit carnet généralement un
cahier qui était ouvert aux yeux de tous
ou vos métiers votre nom votre prénom
votre numéro de téléphone votre adresse
email pour qu'on puisse vous joindre si
jamais il y avait des cas de
contamination dans le restaurant où vous
vous trouviez ça ça reprend mais avec
une grosse préférence pour une version
numérique c'est à dire que dans les
entrées des restaurants et des bars il y
aura des QR code que donc vous pouvez
toujours utiliser la version papier je
le rappelle vous pouvez toujours
utiliser le carnet papier mais vous
pourrez également scanner ce QR code
avec l'application tous antico vide une
fois de plus elle revient et voilà c'est
ça permettra de dire ok vous étiez
présent
[Musique]
bien enfin il est pensé de manière à
vraiment limiter au maximum le fait
qu'il ait donné qu'il partent en fait je
pense la plupart des données sont
stockées sur votre téléphone ça reste en
local cela l'année dernière on a pu voir
quand même des choses qui étaient un
petit peu bizarres
il y a des voilà des acteurs qui se sont
lancés sur le système du QR code qui ont
proposé au restaurateur de mettre en
place ce système avec des données qui
des fois on savait pas trop où elle
partait certains restaurateurs qui en
ont profité pour collecter les adresses
email laissé par leurs clients pour
ensuite les recontacter derrière pour
leur faire des offres commerciales pour
leur dire et coucou n'hésitez pas à
revenir dans notre dans notre chaîne de
restauration parce qu'en ce moment on
fait des promotions ça ce qui était
totalement interdit par la CNIL mais on
a quand même vu des cas là on va dire le
système est totalement repris en main
par par l'État donc c'est pour ça que ça
passe par tous antico vide que les QR
codes générés par les restaurateurs sont
générés partout sont-ils covid du coup
par l'État enfin voilà on il y a
énormément de barrières qui ont été mis
énormément de garde-fous qui ont été mis
pour éviter que voilà vos données
personnelles soient utilisées à tort et
à travers et notamment pour la
prospection commerciale
si vous nous rejoignez sur Figaro live
il est presque 13h30 nous sommes en
direct depuis quasiment une demi-heure
pour aborder le Pass sanitaire et la
nouvelle phase de déconfinement qui a
lieu aujourd'hui à leur n'hésitez pas à
poser toutes vos questions à nos experts
je suis donc avec Chloé Voitier
journaliste au service économiste
spécialiste des questions des nouvelles
technologies et également avec Vincent
Bordenave qui est en liaison Skype avec
nous et qui est journaliste au service
sciences et santé du Figaro et qui peut
répondre à toutes vos questions sur le
covid-19 l'épidémie et la campagne de
vaccination notamment alors Raphaël
lazarek bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous dans le chat de youtube il y a une
question donc le Pass sera-t-il
obligatoire pour voyager à l'étranger
alors oui pour les voyages en Europe
plus exactement pour l'Europe ce sera à
partir du 1er juillet environ faudra que
vous preniez l'avion que vous preniez le
train ou que vous preniez la voiture
pour voyager dans un autre pays européen
il faudra présenter un pass sanitaire de
toute façon en fait c'est déjà un peu le
cas aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas prendre
l'avion comme ça pour aller à Londres
pour aller à Rome pour aller pour aller
en Allemagne vous devez présenter un
test PCR négatif avant de prendre
l'avion donc ça on garde ce principe
mais on rajoute également le principe
que vous pouvez aussi présenter votre
impasse sanitaire donc avec prouvant que
vous avez été vacciné par exemple en
fait chaque pays met un peu ses règles à
des règles il y a des pays dans lesquels
vous pouvez juste rentrer parce que vous
êtes vacciné d'autres pays vont dire ok
vous êtes vaccinés mon aimerait quand
même un test PCR en plus pour prouver
que vraiment vous êtes voilà il y a pas
de risque donc ça c'est en train de en
fait ça évolue un peu au jour le jour
selon les les pays européens donc
tenez-vous au courant avant de partir en
en France la seule chose qui est sûre
c'est que si vous partez en vacances en
Europe et que vous rentrez évidemment
vous allez rentrer en France et ben là
depuis la semaine dernière vous n'avez
plus besoin de présenter un test PCR si
vous êtes vacciné si vous avez terminé
votre schéma vaccinal alors qu'avant on
vous demandez en plus un test PCR donc
ce qui voulait dire prendre un
rendez-vous dans le pays de vous passer
vos vacances trouver un rendez-vous etc
donc c'est pas forcément la chose à
laquelle on a envie de penser quand on
est quand on est en congé quand on est
en vacances de trouver un rendez-vous
dans un laboratoire pour passer un test
donc ça cette limite s'en va ensuite sur
la question des des voyages hors
d'Europe là pour le moment on reste sur
les règles actuelles
c'est à dire que déjà il faut que vous
soyez il faut que les frontières du pays
soient ouvertes ou que vous soyez dans
les catégories qui peuvent voyager donc
ça c'est pays par pays et la règle
actuelle c'est que vous présentiez un
test PC négatif de moins de 72 de 48
heures ça aussi ça dépend des pays et
l'idée c'est que bon ça c'est des
discussions qui sont en cours avec pas
mal de pays notamment les États-Unis de
faire en sorte que le passe sanitaire
puisse aussi être connu mais bon ça on y
est pas encore pour le moment c'est
vraiment le Pass sanitaire c'est
l'Europe
alors Valérie Thonon a une question
l'Espagne a-t-elle le droit d'imposer
d'être vacciné pour rentrer sur son
territoire
faut connaître les règles en vigueur en
Espagne faut connaître les règles en
vigueur en Espagne après
là je vous avoue là je vais pas me je ne
suis pas experte de la législation
espagnole mais en tout cas bon je
c'est leur alors est-ce que c'est ils
obligent ils obligent à être vaccinés ou
est-ce que le test PCR marche quand même
pour rentrer ça c'est
d'après ce que j'avais lu mais je ne
suis pas experte non plus sur le sujet
donc Valérie Thonon je vous invite à
rechercher plus d'informations précises
sur ce sujet on peut pas répondre à
cette question regardez des autorise à
entrer sur le territoire à toutes les
personnes qui ont fini leur parcours
vaccinal mais ça veut pas dire qu'ils
imposent
le vaccin ça veut dire que c'est
beaucoup plus simple de rentrer donc on
va si vous voilà c'est ça que ça veut
dire si vous êtes totalement vacciné
vous n'avez pas besoin de présenter un
test PCR pour rentrer en Espagne alors
que si vous n'êtes pas totalement
fasciné vous devrez présenter un test
PCR de moins de 48 ou 72 heures c'est
quand même une contrainte on va être de
garde c'est quand même une contrainte de
pouvoir de prévoir voilà il faut prendre
un rendez-vous il faut passer le test il
faut être sûr que le test bon
toute une gymnastique toute une
organisation donc ça l'Espagne lève
cette contrainte
alors sans que fortnite à une question
pour pour vous Vincent pourquoi
instaurer un pass sanitaire si la
couverture vaccinale est à 50 % de la
population et que nous entrons dans la
période la moins favorable à la
propagation du virus
pour éviter que le virus ne circule
d'autant plus alors que la situation
s'améliore parce que si la couverture
vaccinale est à 50%, il y a quand même
une personne sur deux qui a pas été
vaccinée et qui est susceptible de
tomber malade
et 50% de la population c'est suffisant
pour avoir une vague épidémique assez
forte pour à la fois engorger nos
systèmes hopitalier nos systèmes
hospitaliers et puis même une
augmentation importante de la mortalité
et qui plus est il y a il y a un
deuxième enjeu à la vaccination et faire
en sorte à ce que cette vaccination
arrive le plus vite possible et c'est
aussi l'utilité de de se passe sanitaire
encourager les gens à se faire vacciner
c'est que plus on vaccine moins le virus
peut circuler et moins la probabilité de
voir apparaître de nouveaux variants
plus contagieux ou qui sont en capacité
de déjouer nos défenses immunitaires
devient devient importante bon plus il y
a personne qui sont vaccinées moins le
moins la chance de voir apparaître et
forte et c'est quand même ça le
principal enjeu des des mois qui
viennent empêcher l'arrivée d'un variant
qui qui réduirait à néant en quelque
sorte les efforts les efforts de la
campagne
merci Vincent j'ai une question Chloé
pour pour vous comment on obtient un
certificat de rétablissement ça fait
partie des preuves qui sont possibles
dans ce Pass sanitaire qu'est-ce que
c'est exactement et comment on obtient
et auprès de qui alors ça c'est vrai que
cette question du certificat de
rétablissement en fait ça laisse croire
que on va obtenir auprès de son médecin
certificat disant vous avez eu le covid
c'est bon vous avez été vous en avez
guéri et tout voilà tout va bien que
c'est un certificat officiel en fait
c'est pas ça le certificat de
rétablissement il va falloir montrer que
vous avez eu un test positif au covid
qui date au maximum de deux mois
et en gros c'est deux mois et deux
semaines donc minimum deux semaines
maximum deux mois ça veut dire que vous
avez été malade donc c'est voilà c'est
officiel vous avez un test qui prouve
que vous avez été malade au cours des
deux derniers mois et cette période de
semaine ça veut dire que vous êtes
guéris donc en fait voilà c'est
certificat de rétablissement c'est
prouver que dans les deux derniers mois
j'ai eu le covid parce que j'ai un test
PCR j'ai un test antigénique qui le
prouve
alors Raphaël astrek pose une nouvelle
question sur le chat du Figaro merci de
nous suivre Raphaël beaucoup de jeunes
en France ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner pour le moment entre
parenthèses ça veut donc dire qu'ils ne
pourront pas partir à l'étranger en
vacances est-ce qu'on peut rassurer
Raphaël alors je vous rassure si vous
n'êtes pas vacciné on ne va pas vous
empêcher de quitter la France il faudra
que vous respectiez les règles du pays
d'accueil donc qui est généralement de
présenter un test PCR négatif donc ouais
on le répète les frontières ne sont pas
fermées aux personnes qui ne sont pas
vaccinées le principe du test PCR
fonctionne toujours
Vincent ça me permet de rebondir sur la
question de la vaccination des des
enfants et des jeunes qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui en France
alors la valcination est ouverte aux
adolescents à partir de 12 ans si je me
trompe pas
elle sera ouvrir le 15 le 15 juin mais
il y a déjà des rendez-vous qui peuvent
être primes me semble et à quelques
jeunes qui sont vaccinés l'objectif il
est ce que je disais un peu tout à
l'heure pour le moment il y a une
personne sur un adulte sur deux qui a
reçu une première dose de vaccin sur 4
qui a une vaccination complète pour se
prémunir d'un risque de rebond
épidémique à la rentrée les
scientifiques expliquent qu'il faut
vacciner environ 90% de la population
adulte ce qui fait 75% de la population
française et 46 millions de personnes à
peu près et donc en vaccinant les
enfants on arrive plus vite à cet
objectif là et on se protège
collectivement vacciner les enfants
c'est pas tant pour les protéger eux
d'une forme grave du covid parce que on
sait que le virus circule dans les
écoles et qu'il y a très très peu de cas
graves il y a une
il y a une je cherche le chiffre mais je
crois qu'il y a 12 mois de 18 ans qui
qui sont morts de cette maladie dans ce
qui est très faible au vu du nombre de
personnes qui ont été depuis le début
depuis le mois de mars dernier ce qui
est très faible au vu du nombre de
personnes malades dans le pays vu qu'on
a
on a des millions de personnes qui ont
été qui ont été infectés et on a voilà
cherché de chercher le cas je cherchais
le nombre on a plus de 6 millions de
personnes qui ont été diagnostiqués
covid et donc cette maladie circule chez
les enfants mais il développe très feux
de forme grade donc le vaccin est pas
tant fait pour les protéger mais c'est
une protection collective pour la
rentrée éviter d'avoir à mettre en place
de nouvelles mesures restrictives
et Chloé quitte des mineurs concernant
le Pass sanitaire est-ce qu'il est
obligatoire également pour les mineurs
alors oui
les lieux où le Pass sanitaire est
obligatoire il s'applique aux enfants à
partir de 11 ans alors pourquoi cette
limite à 11 ans c'est parce que on
commence à faire des tests PCR
antigéniques à partir de 11 ans donc par
exemple si vous décidez d'aller
je ne sais pas à une foire expo qui va
accueillir plus de 1000 personnes ou un
festival de musique cet été et que vous
êtes accompagné de vos enfants voilà
s'ils ont plus de 11 ans ils devront
aussi avoir un pass sanitaire s'ils ont
moins de 11 ans pas besoin si on veut
aller au Puy du Fou par exemple ou un
parc d'attraction par exemple si vous
allez ouais dans un Disney ou Astérix
voilà vous allez devoir il faut que vos
enfants aussi présentent à pas sanitaire
donc évidemment bon s'ils sont pas
encore vaccinés je pense ce sera
compliqué qu'ils aient terminé tout leur
cycle vaccinal d'ici cet été et bah il
se sera pareil test antigénique ou PCR
négatif et je rajoute car je ne l'ai pas
dit les auto tests ne sont pas valables
pour le
si vous nous rejoignez il reste encore
quelques minutes si vous avez envie de
poser des questions à nos experts du
Figaro je suis avec Chloé journaliste
tech au Figaro économie et avec Vincent
en Skype qui nous écoutent qui est
journaliste au service sciences donc
n'hésitez pas si vous avez des questions
à poser sur le Pass sanitaire son
fonctionnement ou sur l'épidémie de
covid-19 et la vaccination en général on
est là pour vous répondre Vincent moi
j'aurais une question pour faire un
petit peu des pronostics pour cet été
est-ce que tous les voyants sont au vert
comme l'été dernier est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à un été comme l'été dernier
où on va enlever le masque et les
chiffres ne l'ont pas augmenté
sur les sur les deux prochaines semaines
on est quasiment sûr que la situation
continuera sur la même dynamique c'est à
dire une baisse des différents
indicateurs donc à la fois du nombre de
contaminations des hospitalisations etc
on peut se projeter assez sereinement
sur les deux prochains mois sur
juillet-août
parce que les vacances scolaires font
que il y aura moins de contamination
entre les enfants et donc moins de
contamination dans un second temps dans
les familles parce que la situation est
quand même assez assez bonne c'est ce
que j'ai tout à l'heure on va passer à
moins de moins de 5000 cas par jour donc
on sera en capacité de de contrôler de
contrôler la moindre la moindre
affection et de surtout remonter le le
schéma de contamination ce qui est plus
important et de façon à éviter que un
malade en contamine d'autre donc on peut
on peut prélever de manière relativement
sereine et penser que l'été 2021
ressemblera à l'été 2000 à l'été 2020
avec une différence c'est que pendant ce
temps on va continuer à vacciner et que
autant l'année dernière on avait toutes
les besoin de croire un rebond de
l'épidémie au mois de septembre là cette
année on peut aussi regarder la rentrée
avec un peu plus de sérénité avec
quelques inquiétudes quand même au
niveau des variances est-ce que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure c'est pour
ça que les formes vaccinales doivent
être maintenues je rappelle les ce que
je disais mais quand 80 on pourra se
considérer à l'abri d'un rebond quand
90% de la population adulte sera
vaccinée c'est ce qui explique que
l'Institut l'Institut Pasteur c'est 46
millions de personnes on vaccine environ
500 000 personnes par jour aujourd'hui
en France qui est beaucoup mais ce qui
est quand même encore ce qui est quand
même encore
il y a quand même encore un gap
important avant d'arriver à cet objectif
est-ce qu'on l'aura atteint dans Le
Lamentin avant le mois de septembre
c'est compliqué le savoir parce que le
rythme vaccinal sera plus le même en
juillet en août mais pour répondre à la
question sur les deux prochains mois on
peut être serein et sur les masques par
contre c'est difficile de répondre à la
question parce que c'est à la fois un
enjeu scientifique mais c'est surtout un
enjeu politique porté le masque dans la
rue sur la plage ça a pas beaucoup de
d'incidences c'est plus un moyen de
rappeler aux gens qui a une épidémie ce
qui est utile c'est de porter le masque
dans les lieux fermés portez masque
quand on est dans des dans des endroits
où avec un peu le premier cité ça je
pense que on pourra pas
on sera obligé de maintenir ce port du
masque pendant tous l'été et sur les en
extérieur c'est vraiment un choix un
choix politique qui qui sera fait d'un
point de vue épidémique il y a pas
forcément de raison de de maintenir dans
la rue que ce soit ce que je disais à la
plage l'exemple qui est pris c'est
toujours les forêts etc mais même dans
même dans une vie comme comme Paris
Marseille etc quand on se promène dans
la rue il y a peu de risques de
contamination en extérieur mais ce choix
là il est plus guidé par des impératifs
politiques au scientifiques le
gouvernement a déjà dit qu'il allait se
prononcer sur le la fin du port du
masque à l'été s'il y a déjà été
envisagé ou pas du tout oui c'est en
discussion Jean-François delfresci
disait aussi que ça paraît être c'est
compliqué pour lui que le port du Mas
soit vendu cet été mais encore une fois
on parle en extérieur et et très peu de
contaminations en extérieur parce que
les voix contamination du virus c'est
les aérosols donc c'est des
microsclettes qui flottent un peu en
extérieur et partent très vite et ce qui
est un peu paradoxal c'est que quelqu'un
qui marche dans la rue doit porter un
masque quand on est une terrasse de café
à moins d'un mètre on n'est plus obligé
de le porter et là il y a un risque de
contamination qui est en tout cas plus
fort même s'il est plus faible à
l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur il est
quand même plus fort que quand
on se promène donc c'est pour ça c'est
une question là il est elle est assez
sensible et je mettrais ma main à couper
sur aucune des réponses là-dessus
sans que fortnite qui est avec nous
depuis le début de ce live sur Youtube
merci Merci à VOUS
une question du coup elle a une question
où il a une question je ne sais pas
a-t-on une sécurité qui nous assure que
le Pass sanitaire sera supprimé à la fin
de l'été pour éviter que cela que le
l'historique du couvre-feu ne se
reproduise qui a duré enfin qui devait
durer trois semaines et qui en finale a
duré quasiment 5 mois oui oui c'est dans
le texte de loi c'est dans les décrets
fin du Pass sanitaire le 30 septembre
merci merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis je vais vous saluer Camille
Charron merci de nous avoir suivi song
for night donc merci beaucoup Raphaël
lazarek merci beaucoup pour vos
questions Christopher Alba et Valérie
Thonon speed Spyder godass Carlo Negri
et j'en passe merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis donc sur Youtube et sur le
Figaro.fr merci beaucoup Chloé merci
Bruno merci Vincent Bordenave
journaliste au service sciences à
bientôt pour un prochain live et
n'oubliez pas de suivre Figaro live à
17h prochain direct avec point de vue
votre émission quotidienne de débat
bonne journée